today we're going to be learning about
the symmetry of functions and all the
different things that attach to that big
concept which is actually going to be
something really useful for us as we go
further into integral calculus now see
I've got an outline here to sort of
chart our way through this we're going
to look at the big idea introduced like
why do we care about this I'm going to
give you a couple of different ways to
define the symmetries of functions I'm
going to introduce some language and
some new names here and I want to
explain what the names are about where
they come from importantly we'll look at
what happens when you have different
kinds of symmetries and you join them
together and then largely we'll kind of
go full circle and return to this idea
of calculus and see one of the
applications in function symmetry so
that's the roadmap let's get started
when it comes to function symmetry what
is the big idea it's very simple
functions just like shapes and other
kinds of objects are used to deal with
they can be symmetrical and their
symmetry if you if you can recognize
symmetry and manipulate it that can be a
really useful thing for us to recognize
so here's a couple of examples here
right you've got this function over here
which I think most people when they look
at even though they don't know
necessarily what the function is they
would say oh that's symmetrical you know
if you kind of flip it over if you
reflect it that's a kind of shape which
is going to be the same on both sides so
we would say that this shape here has
reflectional symmetry and importantly
it's reflectional across the y axis so
if we had a look at a shape like this
and if I said okay well let's look at it
the other way and flip this over like so
there we go it's the same same shape if
I flip it back you're like wait which
one was the original one there we go
it's the same shape whichever way you
flip it across that vertical line so
this is what we mean by reflectional
symmetry in a function this guy over
here is also symmetrical but in a
different way it's not reflectional
symmetry and this time this kind of
shape needs to be spun around
if you rotate it you would have the same
kind of shape so we don't call this
reflectional symmetry we call this
rotational symmetry and I can prove this
to you really quickly by just like
before I can take this same graph and
instead of reflecting it I can rotate it
so let's again go to edit this and if I
spin around once twice
there we go 180 degrees around the
origin that's important then you can see
it's the same shape that we've had
before in fact now there goes the
original wine you're like which one was
which they look identical to me okay so
we can see that whichever way we look at
this when we spin it around if we go the
full 180 degrees around the origin this
has rotational symmetry and which is why
calling back to like to use seven days
we call reflectional symmetry line
symmetry because you can reflect it
across a line in this case left and
right and then this symmetry we have on
the right hand side it's rotational
because we call it point symmetry around
a point in this case the origin so
what's the idea here whichever version
you're looking at and it's actually hard
to tell which one is which until you
squint and look at the numbers on the
axes there you can see for instance this
one's backwards
these guys have backwards and upside
down so if we do a reflection across the
y-axis you have this new graph and if we
do a rotation about the origin zero is
zero it's a fast way to write it you're
getting the same graph so I hope you're
convinced that those are the same and
this is the idea that we're focusing on
function symmetry now how can we use
this knowledge to come up with some
helpful definitions for us well you've
got this first symmetry the one for this
eye this red function and the second
type of symmetry and we can describe it
geometrically in the way that we just
talked about so the geometric definition
for symmetry type one is its reflection
all or reflected reflection all across
the y axis right and then the second
time of symmetry is rotational around
the origin but zero zero
but how do we actually turn that into
something we can manipulate like that
means I can describe which one is which
but I need to algebra here and some of
my function notation to be able to say
well what does that mean in terms of you
know symbols and characters right so
let's just come back to these original
functions when I say this guy has
reflectional symmetry what I mean that
is if you'd pick like some x value okay
let's pick an X hey like say that guy
there let's choose a different color
it's a little more standing up for you
let's pick that guy there that's an x
value of 3 when you go up to the
function you get a Y value looking at my
scale there that looks like it's about 8
right so I would say F of 3 is equal to
8 but to say that that's reflectional
symmetry means that on the other side on
the opposite side if I went putting in 3
positive 3 if I were putting in the
opposite value which is negative 3 I go
up to exactly the same point there I am
lining up to the edge just like I did
before so in this case F of negative 3
equals 8 and I should be able to do this
if I have true reflection reflection of
symmetry all the way across my function
I should be able to do this anywhere
like I don't know what this particular
value over here is let's call it let's
just call it X as I go up to here I get
some value over here I don't even know
what that is it doesn't line up to a
nice spot but if I look across to the
other side and take the opposite of that
you can see this must be negative X and
I'm getting that same value all the way
across so f of X and f of negative X are
giving me the same number so this is the
way that I can algebraically define this
new kind of symmetry here right so I can
say f of X for any value of x 2 3 4 5
whatever and F of minus X or negative x
they give me the same thing
now what about rotation this is not
quite so obvious let's have a look here
at this blue function if I take an x
value again let's pick one like say this
guy here this is 1 that goes up to a
nice convenient spot up there I get a
my value F of 1 I get a y-value of in
this case 0.5 1/2 you can see it right
across this so I'm just going to write
that as F of 1 equals 1/2 now if I take
the opposite value because I've got some
kind of like you know look on the other
side of the axis on the origin kind of
thing right so that's negative 1 over
here
what F value do I get when I test F of
negative 1 well you can see it goes
downward this way so I've lined up to
negative 0.5 so F of negative 1 equals
negative 1/2 now look at this closely
right what happened was I flipped around
from this that's to be from this x value
here I flipped it over to the opposite x
value from 1 to negative 1 and when I
had a look at the corresponding Y values
they also flipped from 1/2 to negative
1/2 now this actually is our Batterson
geometry from u7 again a rotation is
equivalent to two reflections across the
appropriate lines so if I reflect across
in this case the Y axis going
horizontally and then reflect again
across the x axis which goes vertically
you get the same value so if I go down
to here and say what's my algebraic
definition I can say that f of X what's
that equal to well it's a reflection of
a reflection that gives you a rotation
or you might see it sometimes written as
negative f of X equals F of negative x
so there's a negative on both sides so
it's nice and symmetrical did that so
this is a way that we can describe we
can say you know even without looking at
a picture if I can test out and say well
if you put in negative x to this
function do you get out the same thing
as if you put in X or if I put in
negative x do I get the opposite or if I
put in X this is an algebraic way to
define these different symmetries and
this is dynastar to lead us to this next
part here right these are not just
called symmetry type 1 and symmetry type
2 they actually have special names this
first type of symmetry
flexural symmetry when it comes to
functions we call it even symmetry or we
call the functions even functions when
they have this kind of symmetry and
what's the opposite of even well when
you have rotational symmetry around the
origin
we call that an odd function we says it
has odd symmetry okay